so for Brian Williams if you are a
teacher
okay little Brian Williams little
five-year-old comes in okay and there's
another kid let's call him the Macarena
kid since we were talking about him
lost elrios little lost el rios little
Brian Williams lost el Rio says the dog
ate my homework and then Brian Williams
says I think I did my homework but I was
shot down by an RPG in a helicopter
which excuse would you find more
believable literally Brian Williams
excuse for mystery the misremembering of
being shot down in a helicopter is less
believable not figuratively it is
literally less believable than the old
dog ate my homework just for those of
you who missed it this is him
apologizing for lying about being shot
down on this broadcast last week in an
effort to honor and thank a veteran who
protected me and so many others after a
ground fire incident in the desert
during the Iraq war invasion I made a
mistake in recalling the events of 12
years ago I want to apologize I said I
was traveling in an aircraft that was
hit by RPG fire I was instead in a
following aircraft we all landed after
the ground fire incident and spent two
harrowing nights in a sandstorm in the
Iraq desert this was a bungled attempt
by me to thank one special veteran oh it
seems kind of harmless when you put it
that way mr. Williams was a bundled
bamboozled attempt you're a liar you
liar
he lied during the apology yeah he lied
during the apology with the two nights
right yeah yeah he was not in the desert
for two nights
I heard Dana yesterday she said that in
her report she said that the pilot of
the plane that did get shot right saw
Williams
come up to him about an hour later his
plane had apparently landed myself edit
here fun dip half hour to 45 minutes
after the other one and then they took
off and went someplace else
afterwards so he's lying about the two
nights yeah and more importantly he's
lying about lying oh I forgot I
misremembered
how do you miss remember being shot down
with a gun hey well the thing is I don't
know if he's a stupid person because you
have to be stupid to lie to someone
about being shot down and tell I think
my memory is a little hazy it's like
when you're kids you know I mean if your
kid you know takes cookies or take
something he's not allowed to you go did
you do this and he goes now the dog did
it and the mouth is covered with
chocolate playing mouth his mouth is
covered with chocolate I don't remember
taking those Oreos exactly I
misremembered it and you're going no
dummy now I've got a tan your hide Brian
Williams needs to be spanked it needs to
be spanked by the producers at NBC
publicly and I don't mean figuratively I
mean literally bent over their knee
pants pulled down and spanked with
rubber gloves I have a real problem with
people who and what's so funny is this
is just so premeditated in the you know
for the brave men and women of our
military it trying to sort of you know
let's place the attention over here no
you lied about something and here's the
the big takeaway though that's very
important with this this is not a rare
occurrence this is an occurrence where
someone was caught Hillary has lied I
mean politicians in media they're very
similar in the way they are able to get
away with flat-out lies and the big
reason for that is that there's no
accountability there's no accountability
in the leftist media for Brian Williams
who's going to keep him accountable
any of his far left buddies over there
at MSNBC at the NBC MSNBC CNBC what
about his colleagues over there at ABC
CBS no one will
it's an industry that is homogenous and
that it consists entirely of one group
of ideological people and that's why
this was allowed to go go unchecked for
so long and that's why new media is so
important because now someone like
myself someone like Dana someone like
many of you watching this online or on
Twitter you don't need to go through the
gatekeepers no Zuul no snow Zul at which
ties in with Dana
and they hate it the media hates it they
hate that they don't get to decide
what's true and what's not now I'm not
being a conspiracy theorist and saying
chemtrails and flora fluoride in your
tap none of that
the point Oh Alex Jones stuff none of
the Alex Jones stuff the point is that
this has been going on for a long time
this is one area where he was caught and
he's so not used to being caught that
his apology wasn't really even an
apology it was a lie about Howard why he
was caught I just you know I wasn't
caught in a lie I misremembered you
didn't miss remember not being shot down
by RPG fire in a helicopter in Iraq you
stupid dummy he made it up from scratch
exactly if you like this video
congratulations you in the Internet with
an attention span of more than 30
seconds but subscribe we've got more
videos like this and somewhere I just
look like Muhammad and beat my
six-year-old wife for historical
accuracy